my favorite thing in clay motion I think
is the beginning I can even move or
breathe or eat it's kinda magic clash of
clans is a global phenomenon this great
big story took us to the edge of Eastern
Europe to meet this guy I feel I'm like
dr. Frankenstein
it's alive Vlad uses clay to connect
with others and thanks to the Internet
his work reaches far beyond the borders
of Estonia it's our kind of big reward
for me that people watching this being
artisans turning is kind of because our
country is very small not many much
opportunities to realize as artists I
cannot imagine my life without this
every day I'm Scott in childhood at 6h
Chewie young and I took it from my mouth
and start sculpting
that's how started I wanted my clay
figures to be alive and if I can make
clay figures I can make the motion
I decided to volunteer because I think I
could do some good stuff for people
I would kids like a bro assault kid who
was alone so I came closer to talk
behind and so you playing clash of clans
so I started to play as well and we
played together now we're friends I
joined his be open my favorite
characters in the game is a wall breaker
healer
maybe female option I like in the most
of clay figure sees tiny things do
making hair flips eyes fingers details
when I finish this after a long time you
feel it you say huh bless me
you
[Music]